dan randy when you came here we asked
you to make fantasy blades
now we're sending you back to your home
forges to make this
fantastic weapon
attila the huns sword of mars
good luck bladesmiths
i'm back at my home forge and i'm gonna
be making this sword out of damascus
i'm making it damascus to catch the
judge's eyes
damascus you can have all kinds of
problems it could fail on me
but i'm going to take a chance and see
where this one comes out
i've stretched my billet out and i cut
it in six
equal pieces now i'm welding it back
together to go back into forge and forge
weld it and stretch it out i'll have 78
layers
when i get through and hopefully a
pretty pattern
if it sits well i'm home free if i hope
it holds
it's scrapped the well didn't hold it's
got it boyd
i'm afraid if i keep fooling with it i'm
gonna run out of metal
so i'm gonna scrap it start all over
i got three and a half hours of dead and
tomorrow's gonna really be what makes or
breaks the
deal i'm gonna have to push it
so it's the start of day two i wanna get
the heat treat and temper out of the way
and done so i can start working on the
finer details of this blade
this one's for the money there's a lot
of concerns when you make a blade this
long
because if you don't have it even and
flat that gives it more of a chance to
warp
in the quench pull it out of the oil the
blade's got a slight warp in it
but it's hard i still have enough time
to bend it
just a very small window and then i'm
there holding
two blades damn it this sucks
there goes almost a full day of work
time is of the essence
i've gotta get started on another blade
now
this is really gonna suck on day two i
got
my new blade stretched out i wound up
with 13 layers
instead of 78 today i'm starting off
fitting these ball spindles to my guard
i got my ball spindle made just don't
look good it's not a struggle to get it
this far
but i believe i'm gonna start it all
over because it just got too much space
in it
this garden's kind of getting to me it's
really beginning to get on my nerves
it's time to crash this i need this to
work
because if it don't i don't know that
i'll have enough time to start all over
it's the start of day four i lost time
with my first blade time's winding down
now i want to make sure
this is spot-on for the judges thing's a
little thin
but it should be working now i'm gonna
start work
on my handle which is going to be made
out of this little dolphin that i got
from a thrift store
i like to find a use for everything
i want to get the tang burned in all the
way you see how it's not smoking
it means the wood's not touching any
part that's hot i couldn't get the tang
hot enough to burn in
so the only thing keeping me from going
all the way up is the width
here so i gotta stick it in the drill
press and then drill out a little bit
i fit the handle and epoxy it in once
it's on there it's permanent
i can't go back this is insanely
nerve-wracking
if my fit up is loose whatsoever i could
go home
i wish i had more time to make it a
little bit better
oop there goes your cushion
[Music]
it's the last day i've had a few
setbacks
but i'm almost done going to
put some jewels in the handle
attila he was a great leader and i think
the jewels
will be something that he would have in
his
sword i've got my jewels in it
there's one thing left to do etch it and
see what kind of pattern i've got
oh yeah the pattern turned out
well i don't believe i could have done
any better if i had more layers
i think i built the sword that taylor
hun would be proud of
all right bladesmiths to find out what
kind of lethal damage your weapon will
do
i will deliver killing blows on this
with a six dummy
randy up first you ready i am let's do
this
i don't know what to expect and i know
they're gonna hit it hard
i'm a little bit jibbery my legs want to
give out from under me a little bit
but i think i'll be okay
nice
[Music]
all right trying to talk about your
sword of mars here first up
the damascus pattern you have here is
gorgeous all right
the weapon design is very aggressive for
thrusting and slashing
now your handle construction if you
reverse this
it'll be easier to have something to
lock onto the fact that the flare is
right here forcing my hand to open up if
i want to marry
into the hilt this is a very sharp
weapon the tip
pierces all the way through cuts on the
way out
it's pointy and scary and it will kill
all right here
good job all right dan it is your turn
you ready hell yeah let's do this
i was hoping the kill test would be a
dummy i know heads will roll
i'm feeling really confident i want to
see what this thing does
all right dance talk about your weapon
here i love the balance of your blade
when i go forward it's not hard to pull
back
to go in again for another kill now your
handle construction
it's curved enough to where it doesn't
want to fly out of my hand it's got a
good grip and control for this
your edge allows for very deep cuts into
the abdomen right there
the only issue we have is that your tip
picked up a bend
when it's chopped into the spine but
your weapon sir
will kill thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test now attila's armies were
basically one large cavalry
and through his military campaigns he
revolutionized the use of horse
in military conflicts so to test the
strength and durability of your blades
i'll be chopping into these horse skulls
randy over first you ready i guess so
okay
i designed my blade with a sharp sharp
edge
and i'm a little worried my stomach's up
my throat a little bit
[Applause]
so
okay so right off the bat the biggest
thing is
that this section from right about here
to here
has lost its edge there's a couple of
small
rolls blade's still straight
it's all in one piece still solid nicely
done it's very strong blade
thank you all right dan are you ready no
but let's do it
everybody says that the first test bent
my blade
so i'm feeling a little bit of fear
going into the strength test this will
kill blades
it's a scary brutal thing
[Music]
at the guard
[Music]
okay so before we get to the obvious i
really like the design of your blade
it's got a great weight to it had a
really good feel in my hand the balance
was
really nice see all that space around
your tang
with that room for that blade to move
inside the guard
it could just create so much stress that
it cut loose
right there at the corner if it were all
tight there wouldn't be any stress
there's no discoloration here so it's
not that there were it was a crack here
before
your grain structure looks fine it was a
well-designed piece but
obvious law
dan unfortunately your blade suffered a
catastrophic failure in the middle of
our strength test
which means that we can no longer test
it i'd like to invite you to shake our
hands
shake your competitor's hand and then
please leave the forge
it hurts but my sword breaking it's
gonna be a reminder that i have to push
harder and be
better dan keep up the work that's a
good sort i came here to prove that i
can compete with the big dogs and that i
do know what i'm doing and i think i
might have accomplished that
randy the strength and efficiency of
your weapon in the kill test have earned
you the title of forged and fire
champion
and a check for how much 10 000 that's
right 10 000
good job brother i won foraging fire
it's reality
how do you feel good to be a champion
and be
recognized as a good blade smith is all
real good this is my happy and excited
face well then sir
hey if he didn't recognize it
you